how are you feeling how are rehearsals
oh there's been quite a lot that's
happened since we last spoke
it's been great i'll tell you what you
know now we're in the home stretch
before the season premiere and um
i'm feeling i'm feeling great i really
am um you know i've definitely been sore
not gonna lie in places i didn't know i
had on my body
but again you know i mean i'm literally
doing something i've never done before
having to reprogram my brain from 30
years of dancing
you know more urban style dancing to
having really good lines and putting my
chest up
and my head up and actually my head back
that's the thing about ballroom that i'm
that i'm learning is your head
is back like someone's pulling you from
behind when you're not
moving you feel kind of like a dork like
you're just like
this doesn't feel right but then when
you're doing the motions it's like
man that's a lot for you to say because
you you spent a lot of your career being
like one of the coolest
people have you texted nick and said wow
i didn't exactly know
what i was in for with all this i've
actually spoken to him three times now
i called him after the first day of
rehearsal
and i was like oh boy what did i get
myself
into uh and then he he kind of freaked
me out the first time we
you know spoke because granted he was
going based on his experience and
you know this is different for everyone
obviously but he said dude just enjoy it
enjoy them enjoy the process he's like i
wish i would have done a couple things
differently
and he you know listed all these things
and he's like dude just go have fun if
anyone can do this you can do it well i
have
some big news to share with you though i
don't know if he's told you himself
i just talked to johnny weir and
everybody has said
they think he's their biggest
competition johnny said he thinks
you're his biggest competition you know
it's funny i
just actually right before we did all of
this i just met johnny
in the parking lot we were talking car
to car being
at least 20 feet apart i'm a huge fan of
him i love him
and nicest nicest man on the frickin
planet and
i am i mean if i were to say any
specific one of us that i'm a little bit
concerned about
it is it is definitely johnny but you
know even he was telling me he's like
my hips don't move that way you know on
the ice it's a totally different
but that has to feel that is to feel
pretty cool that he's
worried about you here's the thing about
this show is you never know
like there's there's people that have
zero dance experience
that go all the way the season that my
bandmate came in second and bindi irwin
won
she doesn't have any dance experience
it's about the process
johnny did tell me he was an nsync fan
that's okay that was my wife honest to
god
she was an instinct fan she liked their
dancing better than ours
but she liked our songs better and i'm
like wow really
and i still married her you know right
you overcame
yes i'm impressed by that
you said let me okay you've told me that
but i'm going to take you out on a
second date
yeah totally yeah i mean when she was 17
she was the designated driver for her
younger friends
and she drove to see us in vegas wow
she was in the nosebleed sections during
the black and blue tour
and i totally asked her like after we
got engaged i said did you ever think
that day looking down at those guys that
you'd marry one of them she's like
no and leave all you i'm like oh thanks
wow i love it well she's got to be
feeling good about how good you're
looking i know you've been prepping for
all this working out like crazy
on dancing with the stars the guys get
shirtless are you ready to do that
um if they look if they ask me
i'll do it um i i'll tell you what i
feel more confident doing it now
than if this was even nine months ago
how did the dancing with the stars
costume stack up to the backstreet boys
tour looks you used to wear back in the
day you know i mean i've already seen
the kind of design for opening night
um and it's not too far off you know i
mean
obviously things are more formal but
there's certain dances like i talked
with my partner last night
about future dances if we if i make it
that far
based on certain songs like i asked my
partner i said hey can i cut the sleeves
of my jacket off i think i'm the most
tattooed
celeb that's ever done this show so i'm
like that's a big part of me so let's
show it
show it off how are you feeling about
the first dance what can you tease for
us
i'm finally can honest to god say i'm
feeling really good
you know my partner and i have been
grinding it out and
you know again it was pretty easy to
learn the steps
but to do it right that's another whole
other conversation
you know now it's a matter of i gotta
breathe i gotta have fun with it
i don't need a little look like a deer
in the headlights that's not what
america wants to
wants to see is it a backstreet boys
song it is not a backstreet boy song
um it is a song by the weekend
fast okay could we see you pull any of
those old backstreet boys
tour items the clothes any of that into
any of your
your dances you know that would be cool
you know if we end up doing a backstreet
boys song down the road i think it would
be cool
to add some kind of an element from
what the fans know i mean because the
fans know a lot like
if you know if it's the hat routine yeah
you know i mean
that's a pretty pretty signature
backstreet move right there so
i love it also wanted to ask how you
feel about nelly
a fellow music star with you is he a big
competition
and now that you know the full cast who
do your daughters want you to get them
to meet
my daughters definitely want me to at
some point
talk to skye they're both both my girls
are big big fans of jessie
i shocked my friends how many disney
shows that i know and how many
they're all female based girl power
casey undercover all these shows and i
got a bunch of my buddies that want me
to like
talk to oakley and to you know davis and
try to get a
masked selfie i'm like i don't like
bothering people
i'm that guy that even though we're all
equals
in the world of entertainment or like
sports or whatever i don't like to be
that guy
it's just you know i love you and nelly
being on the show together it's like
fulfilling all my dreams
he's nervous but he's gonna do great the
guy's got rhythm he can move
we toured together two summers ago so
you know
yeah i mean he's gonna do just fine aj
you're gonna kill it
go go kick johnny's butt if you can i
know he's nice but you got to win this
mirror ball okay
i know it's all it's all you know
talking
talking shop yeah thanks aj have a great
day we'll talk soon go kill it